♪ ♪
>> Greg: TRUMP IS NO LONGER
JUST A RACIST OR SEXIST, HE IS
AN ASSASSIN NEST.
>> HERE WE ARE IN THE
ASSASSINATION BUSINESS AGAIN.
I'M SORRY, THIS IS THE TOP
GENERAL, HE WASN'T OPERATIONAL,
HE WAS A LEADER.
WE KILLED THIS GUY.
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
THEY USED TO HIDE FROM
ASSASSINATION RESPONSIBILITY.
THIS PRESIDENT IS BRAGGING ABOUT
IT.
I DON'T THINK YOU ARE AN
ASSASSIN, THIS PRESIDENT IS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Greg: A STEP UP FROM
CALLING HIM A REPUBLICAN.
AND AFTER ELIZABETH WARREN
CALLED HIM A MURDERER, SHE FELL
IN LINE QUICKLY, ALSO CALLED
TRUMP AN ASSASSIN.
THEN CAME BERNIE.
>> HE WAS AN OFFICIAL OF THE
IRANIAN GOVERNMENT AND WHAT
WOULD WE SAY IF CHINA DOES THAT?
IF RUSSIA DOES THAT?
RUSSIA HAS BEEN IMPLICATED WITH
ASSASSINATING DISSIDENTS.
IN THE BUSINESS OF ASSASSINATION
YOU UNLEASH SOME VERY TERRIBLE
FORCES.
WHAT I HAVE SEEN NOW IN THIS
WORLD AS A RESULT OF TRUMP'S
ACTIONS, MORE AND MORE CHAOS,
MORE AND MORE INSTABILITY.
>> Greg: YOU'VE GOT TO GIVE
THEM CREDIT, THEY GET ON THE
SAME PAGE FASTER THAN A HORNY
CONGRESSMAN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: THANK YOU, THAT WAS A
PITY LEFT.
BUT BASICALLY IT'S JUST
SOMETHING NEW TO CALL TRUMP.
THE FACT IS WE KILL BAD GUYS ALL
THE TIME.
THE PROBLEM IS, THEY JUST MAKE
MORE, AND THAT SUCKS, BUT YOU
CAN'T BLAME TRUMP, HE DIDN'T PUT
US THERE AND DON'T BLAME HIM FOR
KILLING WHO LIKE KILLING US.
THEY SIDE WITH THE THUGS WITH
AMERICAN BLOOD ON THEIR HANDS,
LEAVE THAT TO COLIN KAEPERNICK,
HE NEEDS THE WORK.
IF THE MEDIA'S NEW TAKE IS WHAT
IS GOING TO HAPPEN NEXT.
THEY ARE PREDICTING BAD THINGS,
WHICH HAVE ODDLY ALREADY
HAPPENED.
CYBER ATTACKS, ATTACKS ON SHIPS
AND EMBASSIES AND SOLDIERS.
IF KILLING HIM MAKES HIM WORSE
THAN THAT I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
HOW LETTING HIM LIVED IT
WOULD'VE MADE HIM BETTER.
ANYONE?
BUT IF YOU THINK KILLING
DIRTBAGS WHO KILL OUR TROOPS IS
A GOOD THING, THE MEDIA MUST
FOCUS ON BAD THINGS TO COME BUT
WHAT OF WHAT YOU IMAGINE HAS
HAPPENED EVERY DAY SINCE HE WAS
IN PRIME TIME.
THAT'S LIKE PREDICTING MICHAEL
MOORE WILL EAT APART.
NO BOOK HE IS GOING TO TAKE YOUR
BED.
AND REALLY THOSE WHO KEEP
PREDICTING THE END HAVE NEVER
BEEN RIGHT.
BUT THAT DOESN'T STOP THEM HERE
THEY WANT THE APOCALYPSE JUST TO
SAY "I TOLD YOU SO."
I MEAN, CHECK THIS OUT.
>> HE HAS PERPETRATED GREAT
SUFFERING AND MISERY IN PLACES
LIKE LEBANON AND YEMEN AS WELL.
BUT THE ISSUE IS, WAS THIS A
WISE MOVE?
>> SOLEIMANI WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE DEATHS OF HUNDREDS OF
AMERICAN COALITION SERVICE
MEMBERS.
BUT EVEN MANY OF SOLEIMANI'S
ENEMIES ADMITTED HE WAS A
MILITARY GENIUS.
>> NO ONE SHOULD BE SHEDDING
TEARS FOR SOLEIMANI BUT AT THE
SAME TIME, THE FACT, AS A MASTER
SHERMAN SAID, THE CONSEQUENCES
OF THIS COULD BE UNBELIEVABLE.
>> WE ARE BETTER OFF WITHOUT
HIM, BUT THAT HAD TO BE
EVALUATED IN THE CONTEXT OF ALL
THE RISKS THAT COME ALONG WITH
IT.
>> Greg: BUT, BUT COME ABOUT.
THAT'S MORE ABOUTS THAN THEY
TELL ME JOHN COMMERCIAL PLAY
EVERY DAY.
BUT WHEN THE MEDIA KEEP SAYING
"BUT," EVERYTHING THEY SAY
STINKS.
THAT'S A LITTLE ANALOGY I
PROBABLY SHOULD'VE LET DIE.
I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
>> I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANYTHING WRONG WITH THE.S.
IT'S REASONABLE TO ASK QUESTIONS
IN THE WAKE OF THIS.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT HIM
YESTERDAY AND
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL."
>> Greg: GREAT BUTT.
>> THAT IS A QUESTION WE SHOULD
ALL BE ASKING AND HE WAS ASKING
OF HIS FELLOW DEMOCRATS.
THE BUTS ARE IN FACT, WE SHOULD
ALL HAVE QUESTIONS.
THAT IS WHY CONGRESS IS BEING
ADDRESSED RIGHT NOW AND TOMORROW
SO THEY CAN LET THEM KNOW WHAT
THE INTELLIGENCE WAS AND WOULD
ULTIMATELY LEAD TO THIS DECISIO
DECISION.
GOING BACK TO ELIZABETH WARREN,
SHE WAS FOLLOWING
BERNIE SANDERS, THE FIRST ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL TO USE THE
ASSASSIN VERBIAGE.
LIZ WARREN FOLLOWED, SHE CALLED
HIM A MURDERER, SHE WAS THEN
ASKED BY MEGHAN McCAIN THREE
TIMES WHETHER OR NOT --
WOULD YOU LOVE TO PLAY CUSTOMER
ASKED ME WHEN I WOULD TO PLAY.
>> ISSUED A STATEMENT CALLING
SOLEIMANI ARE MURDERER AND A
SECOND STATEMENT SAYING AND
ASSASSINATION OF A SENIOR FORMER
MILITARY OFFICIAL.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
FLIP-FLOP.
>> THIS ISN'T A CHANGE, IT'S THE
TRUTH.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT IS THE
RESPONSE THAT THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES SHOULD MAKE?
HE'S PART OF A GROUP --
>> HE IS A TERRORIST.
>> HE'S PART OF A GROUP THAT IS
DESIGNATED TERRORISTS.
OF COURSE HE IS.
>> TO TIE IT ALL IN, JOE
LIEBERMAN FROM WHAT YOU JUST SAW
FROM ELIZABETH WARREN, HE ASKS,
DON'T DEMOCRATS RISK LOOKING
WEAK IN THE SPACE OF EVIL LIKE
THIS AND NOT BEING ABLE TO MAKE
AN ADMISSION LIKE THAT?
>> Juan: LET ME JUST SAY I'M
NOT GOING TO FALL FOR YOUR
FLATTERY.
MY BUTT IS MY BUSINESS BUT I
DON'T HAVE A REAL BUT HERE
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK SOLEIMANI
WAS A BAD GUY.
NEVERTHELESS -- I DIDN'T SAY
BUT.
BUT I DO THINK THAT IT'S
IRRATIONAL, AS YOU WERE SAYING,
TO ASK ABOUT RAMIFICATIONS,
CONSEQUENCES AND THE LIKE.
ARE WE SAFER AS A NATION -- NO,
EVEN YOU SAID JUST A MOMENT AGO
THAT THEY ARE ASKING QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHAT IS TO COME.
>> Lawrence: DO BELIEVE HE WAS
ASSASSINATED?
>> Juan: NO, BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT IS EXTRALEGAL.
THAT IS WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
IF YOU USE THAT TERM AND YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT TAKING AN EXTRA
LEGAL STAFF, MY QUESTION IS, IF
YOU'RE SAYING HE WAS A TERRORIST
AND HE IS AN ENEMY OF OURS, AN
ENEMY OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, IF
WE START KILLING ALL THE BAD
GUYS, WE'VE GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
TO GAIL.
ARE YOU GOING TO GO AFTER
VLADIMIR PUTIN?
YOU WANT TO GO AFTER SOME OF
THESE FOLKS IN LATIN AMERICA?
>> Lawrence: THE PRESIDENT
SAID TODAY, THEY KILL OUR PEOPLE
AND WE HAVE TO BE SENSITIVE TO
THEM AND THEIR CULTURE?
>> Juan: EXACTLY WHAT HE SAYS.
>> Greg: TAKE TWO.
MY GOODNESS, PEOPLE ARE ON TOP
OF THINGS.
WE HAVE THAT TAKE?
>> HE WAS HORRIBLE, HE WAS A
TERRORIST, HE WAS A MONSTER.
AND HE IS NO LONGER A MONSTER,
HE IS DEAD.
AND THAT IS A GOOD THING FOR A
LOT OF COUNTRIES.
I DON'T THINK TOO MANY PEOPLE
CAN COMPLAIN ABOUT IT.
I DON'T HEAR TOO MANY PEOPLE
OTHER THAN POLITICIANS WHO ARE
TRYING TO WIN THE PRESIDENCY.
THOSE OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMPLAINING.
>> Lawrence: THEN THEY PLAYED
VIDEO ON THEIR TWITTER PAGE OF
THE SUPREME LEADER CRYING.
YOU HAVE MICHAEL MOORE PINNING
AN APOLOGY TO THE SUPREME
LEADER.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WRITING
THEIR OBITUARY.
IT'S LIKE, THIS GUY WASN'T A
TERRORIST AND KILLING OVER 600
OF OUR TROOPS?
>> Juan: EVERYTHING YOU JUST
SAID IS NEWS.
WHEN YOU HAVE A SUPREME LEADER
REACTING THAT WAY, THAT IS
INFORMING US ABOUT THE REACTION
ON THE GROUND.
HOW ABOUT THE BIG PROTESTS?
>> Lawrence: SHOULD WE BE
APOLOGIZING TO THEM?
>> Juan: HERE'S THE POINT I'M
TRYING TO MAKE.
IS THE U.S. SAFER?
IS ISRAEL SAFER?
WITHOUT THE IRAN DEAL, ARE WE
SAFER?
ARE WE IN A BETTER POSITION TO
FIGHT ISIS?
WAIT A SECOND, TELL ME WHAT THE
IMMEDIATE THREAT WAS, BECAUSE
THIS GUY HAS BEEN GOING AROUND
PLOTTING TERRORIST --
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE, HE HAS.
IN THE PAST, THEY KILLED PEOPLE.
>> Juan: WHAT WAS THE
IMMEDIATE THREAT THERE?
>> ENOUGH PUBLIC INFORMATION,
REUTERS HAS AN AMAZING PIECE OUT
ABOUT HOW SOLEIMANI WITHIN IRAQ
IN SEPTEMBER AND OCTOBER SITTING
ACROSS THE U.S. EMBASSY IN
BAGHDAD AND TALKING ABOUT THE
WAY THAT THEY WERE GOING TO USE
NEW IRANIAN MILITIAS THAT HAVE
NOT YET BEEN DETECTED BY THE
UNITED STATES TO GO AFTER
AMERICAN TROOPS BOTH IN IRAQ AND
ALL OVER THE REGION.
THERE'S PLENTY OF PUBLIC
INFORMATION ON THAT.
THE PROBLEM IS NOT ASKING
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT MIGHT
HAPPEN NEXT.
THE ISSUE IS THAT YOU ARE
INSINUATING THAT THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS ENTIRE ADMINISTRATION
ISN'T THINKING ABOUT THAT, AND
THEY DIDN'T THINK THROUGH THAT
IF WE TAKE THIS GUY OUT, AND A
GUY WHO WAS ALSO IN THE CAR,
ANOTHER TERRORIST WHO WAS A
REALLY BAD ACTOR, SMUGGLED IN
MOST OF THE IEDs THAT BLEW UP
OUR TROOPS, HE WAS IN THE CAR AS
WELL.
THE INTELLIGENCE ON WHERE THEY
WERE AT THE RIGHT TIME WAS GOOD.
NOW WE ARE QUESTIONING WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN NEXT?
OF COURSE.
BUT THE IDEA THAT WE DON'T KNOW
OR HAVE A PLAN LEADING UP TO
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
ALSO, THEY KEEP SAYING, WELL,
THE PRESIDENT IS INCOMPETENT, HE
DOESN'T KNOW WHAT THE IRANIANS
ARE GOING TO DO, BLAH, BLAH,
BLAH.
THEY'VE BEEN ON THIS GUY AND
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION APPEASED THE
REGIME OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
SOLEIMANI HAD SANCTIONS AND
TAKEN OFF OF HIM AS A RESULT OF
THE IRAN DEAL, AS A RESULT OF
BARACK OBAMA'S NEGOTIATION ON
THAT DEAL, YET HERE WE ARE TODAY
QUESTIONING WHETHER TRUMP WAS
THE ONE APPEASING THE IRANIANS?
>> Lawrence: YOU WERE ONE OF
THE DEMOCRATS SAYING
PRESIDENT TRUMP ALWAYS QUESTIONS
OUR INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES.
OH, WAIT A SECOND -- WAIT A
MINUTE.
EXCUSE ME --
>> Juan: WAIT A MINUTE.
STOP THE PRESSES, STOP
EVERYTHING.
JUAN WILLIAMS IS GOING TO QUOTE
TUCKER CARLSON.
TUCKER CARLSON SAID WAIT A
MINUTE, IT'S PEOPLE LIKE
LAWRENCE SAYING THIS IS THE
DEEP STATE, THE TRUMP
DEEP STATE, IT'S TERRIBLE.
NOW WE LOVE THE DEEP STATE!
TUCKER CARLSON, HATS OFF!
>> Greg: BUT YOU CAN SAY BOTH
THINGS.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO TRUST ANY
INTELLIGENCE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO TRUST IT BUT
YOU CAN STILL KILL THE GUY.
YOU CAN DO BOTH!
>> Juan: YOUR POINT WAS WE
DON'T TRUST THE PRESIDENT
BECAUSE WE THINK THE PRESIDENT
ISN'T THINKING THINGS THROUGH.
THIS PRESIDENT PUT SANCTIONS,
ECONOMIC SANCTIONS ON AND THEY
HAD EFFECT, SO WHY DID HE HAVE
TO KILL HIM?
>> THEY HAVE IN FACT.
THE IDEA THAT WE NEED TO GO IS
RIGHT NOW.